Chantal is with us in Maryland hey
Chantelle how are you hi good how are
you better than I deserve what's up
so my question I guess is for both you
guys is it wrong for me to not want to
date or like get into another
relationship until I'm debt free or at
least closer to being debt-free did you
blow up the last one relationship with
the debt so yes suppose I was in a
pretty long-term relationship about like
six or seven years and it just didn't
work out well and it's not when I was
really young so uhm so what's your
hesitation what's your hesitation of
dating so my while you're working on
your debt I guess being rejected because
of it oh that's a good one Dave you've
got reason you've got a doctorate in
psychology that was it right to it oh
sorry about that no that's a step in
your space oh man all of you right now
that was a pretty good move it sounds
like you're not worried about the dead
it sounds like you're trying to come up
with a couple of reasons inside your own
heart and head to not get back out there
is that fair that's a fair statement yes
so you are bigger than your debt you're
worth more than your debt and if you
will honor and love yourself you're
gonna make somebody else very very happy
let's pretend the cause for rejection
was something else that was permanent
like a physical thing you lost a limb in
a car accident okay then you would say
I'm bigger than that I'd get back out
there you you're you have a wound of the
wallet that's embarrassing and
potentially would repel some people
right so the metaphor of the lost limb
probably plays a little bit right right
so I listen if you were coming into to
date one of my kids I would say
you are worthy to be dating a Ramsay kid
they're married by the way but and the
reason is this it's not about the debt
it's about the fact you realized this
wrong and you're getting out of it
the ones that that the deal-breaker for
me would be if I were advising a couple
would be that you're not in agreement on
this he hates debt and you love it now
that you shouldn't be dating okay cuz
you're gonna you're gonna break up
you're not your marriage is gonna break
up later because you got a long road but
if he's like yeah I'm completely debt
free I hate debt and she's got a pile of
debt but she's beautiful this is worth
it I'm doing this and you jump on the
thing together and you kick the debts
but together
I'm game on that I don't think you ought
to be I've had a lot of couples ask me
over the years you know I don't I told
her I won y'all marry her until she was
dead free well I told her I told him I
told her she shouldn't marry you because
you're an idiot so I mean that's the way
I feel about I think you may get
rejected by some people
Anthony O'Neill's got a great story
about how he got rejected by a girl cuz
he was on a budget and she won't date
some guy with a budget I think he said
that when he came to gatorsburg that's
called the matrix size dodging a bullet
on his part right there yeah definitely
so I don't know Chantelle I what do you
think III I think you I think you get
back out there and go rock and roll I
don't think I think I think that the the
debt is the debt is the debt is
something you're carrying around to keep
you from getting hurt again set it down
yeah the debt is not a disqualifier the
fact you won't attack it would be a
disqualifier I'm irresponsible with
money I got to get my act together and
be on a budget awhile and act like a
grown-up before a date yeah that might
be okay but I got debt and I'm attacking
it that's not a disqualifier okay I love
it I love it I love it